"THE NAME'S GUY, BOND GUY." TO
HELP US WITH THIS GAME, THE
STAR OF HEMLOCK GROVE, THE
GREATEST BOND GIRL OF ALL
TIME, XENIA ONATOPP, SO PLEASE
WELCOME FAMKE JANSSEN.
>> I LIKED BEING A BOND GIRL.
THE BEST THING ABOUT BEING A
BOND GIRL IS THE NAME.
HOW CAN YOU COMPETE WITH NAMES
LIKE PUSSY GALORE, HOLLY GOOD
HEAD AND OCTOPUSSY.
I PERSONALLY THINK, WHAT ABOUT
THE MEN?
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S TIME FOR A
BOND GUY.
>> CHRIS: I WAS SAYING THAT.
>> YES. MEN DESERVE TO HAVE
SEXUALLY PROVACTIVE NAMES.
OKAY YOUR NAME.
I MEAN IF YOU WERE A BOND GUY.
I THINK YOUR NAME WOULD BE LIKE
CHRIS HARDWICK.
>> CHRIS: YES, NO.
IT WOULD BE, IT WOULD JUST BE MY
NAME.
MY NAME SOUNDS LIKE I'M A 70S
SOFTCORE CANADIAN PORNAGRAPHER.
THERE SHOULD BE BOND GUYS. THERE
SHOULD BE BOND GUYS
I WANT YOU TO COME UP WITH AS
MANY BOND GUYS NAME AS YOU CAN.
FIRST LET'S GIVE IT UP FOR FAMKE
JANSEN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> CHRIS: YOU CAN LEVITATE ME
WITH YOUR MIND IF YOU WANT.
NO? OKAY.
I AM PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
>> SETH MORRIS.
>> STIFF HARDDICK.
CHRIS: POINTS.
PETER.
>> OCTOGLAND.
CHRIS: POINTS.
JOHN.
>> URI EATHRA.
>> POINTS. SETH
>> BUSTER HYMAN.
>> YES POINTS.
>> FILL UP FROM BEHIND.
>> PETER.
>> BALLS GALORE.
CHRIS: IT SOUNDS BETTER WHEN
YOU SAY IT.
JOHN.
>> BARE VON DEE, DEES NUTS.
CHRIS: RAISE IT UP.
RAISE IT UP.
YA, POINTS.
SETH.
>> TWO PUMP PAUL.
CHRIS: POINTS.
PETER.
>> GOLD FINGERER.